foreign
and welcome to everyone
uh we're here for our live look at the
digital marketing boot camp with Purdue
University
um powered by meta and delivered by
simply learn
have uh
Bernadette Chambers here who will be
taking us through the learning
management system and also sharing some
of your insights in the digital
marketing world
he's one of the top trainers digital
marketing and certainly simply learns
top trainer and she's also an
entrepreneur who runs her own
uh business socialite Hive but I said
that correct and it has extensive
experience in digital marketing digital
transformation
SEO as a special Focus so
welcome Bernadette thank you for being
here and I'm going to go ahead and talk
about the agenda
for today's session
and thanks for inviting me uh-huh we'll
be talking about digital marketing
careers which is why everybody's here
um and then we'll we'll describe what
this particular boot camp program offers
to you
um how it's going to get you job ready
I believe it's a tour of the learning
management system that Bernadette will
conduct
and we'll talk about enrollment steps
and we'll take your questions about the
program
the industry so
let me
proceed
with an overview of digital marketing
this career so the digital economy
requires digital marketing that under
sounds obvious but it's not really
um we really learned that lesson
in much more
feel and much more emphasis when the
pandemic hit because up to that point
digital marketing was something that
maybe Amazon did it and maybe
um stores were just experimenting with
e-commerce and so they were looking at
that and it was very popular and growing
field and well Bernadette's been making
her living for
but when the pandemic hit
suddenly we went to remote work
non-contact
transactions
couldn't go into a store so you had to
conduct Business Online
and that meant all marketing
really turned into digital marketing in
one way or another
so it's a different world today and that
has just accelerated the trend that was
already tending towards digital
marketing
so Word of Mouth ask media advertising
things that we took for granted
decades ago
given a way to
social media as how you present Word of
Mouth to your peer group
online advertising even if you do see a
television ad
a good chance you'll see a QR code in it
which will take you to a digital channel
so all of these different aspects and
the fact that brick and mortar
businesses have had to take on digital
personas and digital operations have
transformed the industry and created a
much bigger demand for digital marketing
so
Could you um Bernadette share what your
view is of the transformation we've been
undergone
absolutely so
um again thanks so much for inviting me
Stuart I definitely love coming onto
these Costa shits I'm like so the
industries across the board are kind of
in this weird parallel between trying to
figure out if there are going to go with
just what they're coining RTO return to
office or if they're going to keep
everything the same because of how the
customer Behavior has shifted
customers are still very much trained
um in being able to order things offline
and being able to have online
experiences with the products and
services that they get and they almost
prefer it that way because now it's more
of a convenience than having to get in
their cars and drive and so companies
are faced with the unique challenges of
how to increase the customer experience
that's like their number one thing and
they're relying on the data to tell them
every piece of data is a touch point and
so in terms of digital marketing this
field is Evergreen and just to give you
a little bit of insights a lot of these
major tech companies are putting more of
their budget in their ad sales in their
digital marketing sales because they
know that companies are wanting to
basically transform their organizations
to go into much more of a digital
approach more than traditional because
of the way that the customer Behavior
has shifted post pandemic so that is why
this field is definitely a field to be
in I've been in this field for 10 years
I have seen pretty much everything that
you could possibly think of and just to
watch this Paradigm Shift of what's
happening with the way that customers
are behaving is what's driving companies
to want individuals like yourself to be
trained in this field
great thank you appreciate that um
and you know having a set of digital
marketing skills gives you a lot of
different paths
um probably of the different technology
skill areas that simply learns involved
with
digital marketing may have the most
diversity of different paths that you
can
follow
um
you can
of course consolidate them all and build
up a career as a digital marketing
manager or VP of marketing that type of
thing but along the way work as an SEO
analyst email marketing content
marketing social media
one of Bernadette's particular
Specialties
website marketing e-commerce
merchandising and marketing uh
pay-per-click
all the different types of roles and the
the great thing is that if you cross
train into multiple
skill sets and roles you're able to be a
more valuable contributor to digital
marketing campaign because you'll
understand what the other members of the
team are doing and what what's
the best way for you to support them so
you know we talk about these skills that
were in the middle of that bubble SEO
content marketing web analytics so
important because you need to understand
what the result is of your program
campaign
um website management and optimization
so that when people do get to that
landing page that you maximize the
results you get from it social media
email marketing
pay-per-click and AD testing
keywords
um all of these different skills
contribute to a well-rounded digital
marketer um
do we have a fairly comprehensive list
here Bernadette
yes it is and just to add a couple of
things I like to like in digital
marketing to almost the medical field
you have a general practice doctor who
basically does a little bit of
everything but when he runs into a
situation that he is not equipped for
then he might refer out to a
Cardiologist or optometrist or a
Pediatrics or whatever the case may be
this follows that same concept it is
great to know all of these different
areas because these are the domains and
the disciplines that build up and
comprise digital marketing as a whole
but we don't want to be the the master
of meaning what is it the Jack of all
trades master of none right so it's very
important to look at which one of these
really sticks out with you and which
ones that you would like to pursue
because there's all sorts of benefits
for having a specialization in addition
to your general knowledge as for myself
I am well versed in all of these areas
but my specialty is PPC strategy and
social media strategy so media buy
because media buying is top tier right
now and everyone wants to expand Their
audience against their their current
audience and build their audience and
know one way to do it to sidebar and
Sidetrack uh well to help with some of
the time that it takes to build SEO is
to do with paid media so this is very
well uh written in terms of the amount
of opportunities and you guys can
definitely research more about that
hey thank you so much
so we have a couple of questions for you
along the way and the first one we're
going to ask it's a pretty simple one
get that started for you uh if you're
watching on our streaming service on uh
YouTube you can put your answer ABC or D
into the comments but let me start this
Poll for our WebEx audience and here we
go
so uh
you're here today to learn about a boot
camp program what has stopped you up to
now from undertaking one of these
programs is it because you couldn't find
one that covers all the the skills we
just discussed uh is it because you
can't find one that gives you confidence
that you'll be able to say I've got
hands-on experience with digital
marketing now
um do you have difficulty programs that
just offered you pre-recorded videos
or is it a scheduling problem finding
the time to do the
educational work
in between your working hours so
leave this open for two seconds longer
here we go
and
almost two-thirds of the audience say
that the biggest concern is
program that doesn't let you confidently
say that
you've got practical experience using
digital marketing tools and skills and
you can prove it and then you have
around a quarter of the audience for
each of the other uh answers so let's
move on
talk about how this program addresses
these concerns
so again this is a program offered in
collaboration with Purdue University
they provide the program advisor advise
us on the curriculum we partner with
them and with the
meta for the content and
some of the certifications and it's a
program that takes six months to
complete you need to devote 10
maybe a little more than 10 hours a week
to it because you will have
live
virtual classes that you attend for
eight hours a week
um that's the one thing that's scheduled
that you have to make set times for the
rest of the week you can do the rest of
the work on your own time on your own
schedule
it's all done online on web browsers so
you do
exercises on your laptop or desktop
computer but you can also
access much of the material and do some
of the exercises on a mobile device so
it's extremely flexible and allows you
to fit the rest of that
coursework into the hours you have
available in your personal schedule
again the Integra the
virtual classrooms allow you to interact
directly with an instructor like
Bernadette
um go through the exercises
fear the other instructors will take you
through uh
projects labs and real world type
problems and guide you through solution
methods
and answer your questions live and
you'll be able to interact with your
classmates
and then during the week you you can
reach out email questions to your
instructor go to our community
page and ask other members of the class
or
contact our support 24 7 support people
so this is a something that you can do
from
Wherever Whenever
and it's
very flexible and
fit into almost any
lifestyle or schedule so
what you end up with at the end of this
program is a certificate that attests
Purdue University attests to the fact
that you have completed the core courses
that you have demonstrated the skills
that you can back that up
and do that through the Hands-On
projects including a Capstone project
that is the final step in the program
talk more about that in a minute you get
master classes with Purdue you'll also
get classes and content from meta and
I'll mention more about that but you do
get an exam voucher for the
meta-certified digital marketing
associate as part of this program and
you also get eligibility for the Purdue
alumni association so you have the
ability to network with other people
who've gone through their professional
development programs and that's a great
career building opportunity that you
keep with you for life so
Purdue University is
then people know it's 151 year old
University established in Indiana it's
one of the oldest and one of the uh top
public universities in fact one of the
top universities in the world and
we've had Nobel Prize winners come out
of her Purdue and a number of other
um
loadables so it's a very prestigious
institution and it's name is recognized
worldwide so that'll
that'll be something you'll see on your
resume that people will notice
we also talk about the the connection to
meta and of course meta is the new name
for the parent company of Facebook but
you get uh ask me anything sessions
master classes and as I mentioned the
voucher which allows you to take their
certification exam for the associate
program and
so you end up not only with certificate
from
Purdue and simply learned but you also
can earn the certificate from
meta so
this really gives you a lot of
credibility as a digital marketer once
you've completed the program
um
Bernadette you have a lot of direct
experience with people who've taken the
programs
come out and what can you tell us about
you know the
the way that people come in and the way
they come they leave the program
yeah so to be very transparent there is
a lot of different areas that we cover
and a lot of my students are brand new
to the industry they haven't had
extensive knowledge they only have the
consumer knowledge and I call the
consumer knowledge because they're
interfacing with the platforms but all
of the inner workings and ins and outs
they have no idea and no clue by the
time they have finished a program with
us they have more than enough knowledge
and I always give them the send-off of
this is not your only stop stop here you
really have to focus on building new
knowledge because there's going to be
changes that come down the Pint but the
foundation that they leave the program
with is very strong for them to build
off of for any changes that will take
place with the platforms because as you
guys know these platforms change as
often as the updates on cell phones
change so when you see an update on a
cell phone you can just about bet that
there's going to be a change on any
digital marketing platform form
including Google yep and it's
interesting
that even something like Netflix which
everybody thinks of as an entertainment
platform is now turning into an
advertising platform because they're
they've decided that to solve their
problem of
Rising prices for their subscribers that
they're going to take on Advertising
well that creates a whole new channel
for digital marketers so yep
industry is changing evolving and
it's good to
with a program like this as Bernadette
said to have that Foundation that you
can build on and then pivot as the
industry changes and to get into this
program
um the prerequisites are very simple
um you need to be 18 years of age and
have a high school diploma
I do not have to have work experience
you don't have to have more than what
Bernadette says is the consumer view of
digital marketing
um because this program will take you
from the very Basics to that level of
expertise so
um this is a program that is designed to
be open to everybody and useful to
everybody if you have
more extensive experience if you for
example are
well versed in SEO techniques and you
want to learn a broader range of skills
this is also a great program for you so
I'm going to ask I think the next
question which is you know in our
audience
food
do we have in terms of experience levels
today
I'll leave this open for about 20
seconds
I'll add that even the folks that have
experience with a lot of these platforms
or a lot of these skills they still
learn a lot when they take our program
because a lot of the things that they
learned is kind of obsolete so they're
like I need to refresh my knowledge so
if they do have experience it is a great
refresher for you to know what industry
standard because we always teach based
off of what's happening in the industry
currently not relying on Old notes old
textbooks old things that might be
obsolete right so we have uh a little
over half the audience are people who
have
under two years of experience people who
may still be in school or out of school
um at the University level but um
the rest of our audience are people with
two to
infinite number of years of experience
so
um it's good to see that almost a
quarter of you have more than 10 years
of experience and that's always an
interesting
distribution of experience in these
audiences so
um we'll talk about now how the program
prepares you so rather than have me
show you slides I'm going to ask we're
going to do that to go ahead
and share her screen
already I'm going to give you the
sharing privilege right now
and she can show you the learning
management system
itself
yep so if everyone in the chat will
confirm that they can see my screen
all right and just FYI uh there is going
to be a question and answer segment so
we will get to that in just a bit so
you're not being ignored if you've asked
a question we just have a special
segment for that
um but this is the LMS system that you
all would have access to and the first
class is a welcome class for uh the
Purdue digital marketing so basically it
covers everything that we're going to
cover in the class uh for the entire
time that we're together which is
roughly around that six to eight week
Mark if you're taking the full class or
it might be a shortened period for the
boot camp
now in the fundamentals of digital
marketing and SEO we talk about those
fundamentals and then we dive into SEO
and I'm just going to click here real
quick so that you guys can see some of
the projects that the students actually
have I'm going to move this to the side
so that you guys can see the full screen
so basically inside of this you have
your instructor-led courses where you
would meet with an instructor like
myself where we would teach you like
specific Concepts and how to apply them
in real time but these particular
courses or courses to help you to build
that knowledge so that you're not
completely lost whenever you get to
class and then here you will also see in
the assessment section there is a
project here there's a project here that
all of the students have completed now
in my particular classes I don't know
about other instructors but in my
particular classes I actually have a
built-in mechanism where I have them to
submit to me so that I can provide
feedback I have a very interactive class
in class and out of class and so what I
have them to do is I have them to submit
their project and then I take a look to
see how it is and there are some folks
that put together some really amazing
projects but as you can see these are
all mechanisms that are used inside of
the digital marketing piece so every
project that you're doing is what you
would be doing in real time if you were
deploying a SEO project a social media
project so on and so forth I'm gonna go
back real quick
next you have pay per click so I
actually walk them through pay-per-click
campaigns let them take a look at how
they work all of these different areas
then they have web analytics where web
and analytics is very Hands-On it's a
lot of fun class and basically they work
with a a demo account that's called the
Google merchandise store where they
actually are able to log in in real time
and conduct little research activities
to find out how much they know about
Google analytics and some of the folks
that I have had that have experience
with web analytics have reported that
they've never seen anything like the
exercises that we have for web analytics
and even uh reporting that they didn't
know some of these areas in web
analytics actually even existed so this
is a really really fun class where you
get to dive in Hands-On learn how to
leverage web analytics by basically just
trial and erroring yourself and then I
come in and help to shape or the
instructor comes in and helps you to
find the correct way to access this
information and interpret this data
next you have social media marketing
which focuses on the psychological and
um and content aspects of social media
marketing a lot of times people look at
Social Media Marketing in theory as just
a task oriented domain or discipline
inside of digital marketing but it
really has a lot to do with the
psychology of the buyer what they're
looking for when they go to social media
and what do they hope to gain whenever
they encounter products that they need
so we marry all of those Concepts
together
with some of the other concepts with the
foundationals and things like that then
of course this is actually an elective
that you can take or not take it is
brand management I do not teach this
class live
um it is a self-learning class so you
can definitely take that on your own and
it follows and mirrors the same
structure except it does not have an
instructor-led piece but you can go
through watch the lessons there are some
eBooks there and then there's an
assessment as well where you're able to
test the knowledge that you have
after that let me just go back real
quick the last thing is the Capstone
course so basically what the Capstone
does is helps you to put together all of
your knowledge in one space you're going
to do a project that basically touches
on every area that we have taught you so
it's pretty much a a
project-based course and your crafting
Solutions or crafting different types of
strategies that you would present to the
project management team now what I have
heard students say the ones that did not
have the experience but wanted to break
into the field I have had students
report to me that they took these
Capstone projects along with them for
internship opportunities as well as
entry level opportunities and they were
able to land those opportunities because
of how robust and and the amount of work
that they put in for these projects to
show that you know I may not have
implemented this in real time but this
is what I did
um and this is how I shape this and this
will be the exact framework that I would
put towards a campaign with your company
and they found some companies found it
really impressive and hired them or
onboarded them for an internship so
these tools are definitely useful for
you guys to use and everything that we
do has an application model that is
built into it once you have completed
all of these and you unlock your your
program certificate and as Stuart said
you can present to employers or present
on your Revenue your resume that you
have uh explored these Concepts and
mastered them
and that's it for me back to you great
thank you Bernadette and
you know along with managing your your
program uh courses and curriculum you
have tools within the learning
management system as I mentioned to uh
interact with your peers in your class
and
ask for support and that type of thing
so you have everything you need within
the online environment
that's one of the nice things about this
program is that it's not requiring you
to go from one environment to another or
one system to another but you can get
everything
through this basic single
interface and single source so that's a
great thing
so you're showing the example of the
community right
so this is a
great way for you to be able to interact
with ask questions if you're stuck on
something at three in the morning pose
the question of the community or contact
one of our support people and that way
you can continue your work on your
schedule so with that I'm going to go
ahead and go on to the rest of the
presentation thank you so much
Bernadette for that
and
we are
so we toured the learning environment
and saw the curriculum
the projects including the Capstone
course
and how it tracks and takes you through
the sequence of classes
and there is a specific sequence the
course is designed so that the
curriculum builds up your skills in a
certain order so that you can add on
these skills once you've mastered a
certain set
after the program introduction
orientation course you move on to an
overview of what is marketing how does
it differ from sales different from
other aspects of business
and then move into search engine
optimization search engine marketing you
go into content marketing email
marketing
um
ins and outs and mobile marketing
analytics again is
Bernadette said a very key part of the
skill set to understand your results and
then conversion optimization to maximize
results
and finally the Capstone project that
ties it all together along the way
no extra cost you go to the electives
based on your level of Interest
your schedule and you can take
master classes from Purdue instructors
you can also take master classes or
other activities from meta instructors
so
those enhance
what you get out of the program itself
you get exposed to just a
wide variety of tools and platforms that
you get some real world experience in
using so that when you finish the
program you get to say yes I am familiar
with these tools I've actually used them
so I know how to apply them in any job
that you might give me so this is a
great way to build up your resume and be
able to back up again the skills and
tools that you've listed on it
um and then finally as Bernadette went
through the Capstone project so
you get to choose a Capstone project
from several different domains and
industries
um you it poses for you a real world
type problem the kind of problem that
you might be assigned uh by an employer
in your new job and
you develop the solution with your
instructor acting as Mentor make sure
that you don't go down the dead end
but when you end up
completing the project that it really
does show off your experience the best
light
this is really
as Bernadette said
extremely valuable part of the project
or program that you can use to leverage
into a new job
uh the program leader from the Purdue
side is Jensen Lee
and is an assistant professor of
management
he oversees the integration of our
curriculum with our delivery and also
assigns the master class instructors
so
we worked very closely
with Purdue to make sure that this is a
elite level program
look at the outcomes
I put up a number of testimonials from
people who have
graduated from a digital marketing
programs and
it's great to see for example people
from all over the world from
Jamaica from U.S from other continents
um
it worked from Jamaica
leverage the program into a
really Advanced position
um so we're very proud that we have
this uh this level of satisfaction from
our users and that's level of success
and one of the reasons we do is we offer
Career Services part of the program
so this is a us-based program and uh
the boot camp in particular is targeted
to U.S users
we provide career service in association
with a company called Talent Inc
um so the
assessments that we offer you is
multi-level one is we give you access to
ongoing education and
rear webinars and that type of thing
to keep your excuse me that's my cat's
tail that you just saw
um
we also
provide of course the
projects that will go into your personal
portfolio and then finally the job
assist services and I'll talk about
those right now
with Talent Inc you get access to an
exclusive set of jobs through their job
portal
which
gives you total discretion so that your
current employer doesn't see
you possibly applying for a new job
um
we also give you an important
vital service for resume revamping
that their resumes don't go directly to
people's desks they go through AI
screening systems so your resume needs
to be formatted in a way that the AI bot
will
be able to compare it to the
job description requirements and pass
you on to a human
and that that creation that rewriting of
your resume is a kind of an artwork form
so we assigned to you someone who will
help you with that take you through a
couple of rounds of redrafting your
resume and make sure that it's not only
functional for the AI bot but also still
functional for the humans who will see
it afterward
and then we do the top interview service
which gives you
for your webinar pardon me career
interview training practice
also some career mentorship and allows
you to present yourself in the best
possible light when you're doing direct
interaction the people who are
interviewing you whether it's a
technical interview about your digital
marketing skills per se or whether it's
a
behavioral interview about your soft
skills and your fit in with the team so
um that's extremely valuable
again anytime that you're going to be
looking for a job or building your
career to another another level
you're going to have to go through
multiple rounds of interviews so
we also offer the webinars
um and Bernadette has conducted some of
those as well where we talk about
specific skills or
aspects of the industry or
how to use
examples job board how to develop your
career in different ways
so this is part of our ongoing education
that supports our Learners and alumni
and
talked about the Capstone projects
building your portfolio
here's a representative sample you can
choose to do one from the travel domain
or banking Financial Services or from
consumer goods or from hospitality and
depends on which one interests you the
most and where you think you would be
able to do the best job and
the this again builds up your portfolio
something that you can show to people
but now that we've given you this basic
overview
I want to ask the quick question are you
interested
in potentially enrolling in this program
and I will open the poll
So based on what you know so far
that's no
about another 10 seconds
and here we go
and
so 100 of the people who answered the
poll
are interested in enrolling in the boot
camp so let's talk about how to do that
I think that's a testament Bernadette to
your
um
really thorough and enthusiastic
description of the program
oh I wasn't alone okay
uh the enrollment steps are very
straightforward you start off by
emailing us and ask us at simply
learned.net
um they'll tell you what you need to
submit for the application
this is one of our programs that has
less stringent
prerequisites but they will ask you for
certain documentation and also possibly
evaluate certain areas of your aptitude
and from that
you will get an admission letter if
you're approved
and next cohort for this class starts
November 7th with an orientation so
that's coming up in a couple of weeks
and the classes themselves start in
January
program cost
the fixed U.S
eight thousand dollars
but you can finance that off zero
interest financing as low as 700 a month
704
so um you can also contact your employer
and find out if you're eligible for
tuition reimbursement we always
recommend people do that that's
between you and your current employer
and
for more assistance again to ask more
questions you can ask us at
simplywear.net I will
in the chat right now
place the link to the program page and
to that email address so that you have
that at your fingertips
there you go
in a couple minutes when we're done you
can visit that link
mail us at
ask us at simply learn so we'll move on
to questions and answers and see
who in the audience might have some
questions for us
um
see the one question uh Bernadette
answered why we've changed the names of
some of our programs
and the
as you can see from her answer
you're looking in the Q a
um
some of the programs have requirements
which
stipulate that only people with degrees
can start them
this program does not so it's a boot
camp program and that makes it
accessible to everybody
and also fairly equally valuable in
terms of the curriculum
so
you have any other
audience questions here today
please put them in the chat or in the Q
a
so this program is a six month
program
follows a fairly structured sequence as
I should before
and it's something where you're you're
sequence of courses Builds on one
another so you do want to follow that
curriculum and that schedule fairly
closely
then
meta
certificate voucher exam voucher uh
allows you instead of spending any
additional money out of pocket you
present that and get
a test for the
digital marketing associate from meta so
um and it's one more questions come in
so Bernadette somebody coming from an
I.T background is this a good way to
Pivot to a new career
foreign
yeah so
um I have a lot of students that pivot
from an I.T background it actually kind
of gives you a leg up if you're working
with it depends on what type of I.T so
if you are cloud-based or a developer
and you had access to certain types of
customer data then this will be a good
pivot
um but if you work primarily with just
hardware and infrastructure then this
would be kind of like you learning
something brand new uh but I've had a
lot of students that have come from just
different I.T backgrounds that have done
well in this program so it doesn't
handicap you it just helps you to
understand some of the nuances of how
customer behavior is actually working
because you've worked with the back end
of it particularly if you have like
cloud-based knowledge or working with
the cloud then you'll definitely do well
with this pivot because cloud-based uh
cloud-based experience is definitely
right along the lines of digital
marketing yeah and I would add to that
that if you have experience with with
Cloud if you have experience with uh
data analytics or any of that type of
thing that just means that you have a
little bit of an advantage over the
other people in digital marketing boot
camp because you understand more about
how the tools will ultimately be
deployed and how they'll they'll work
out in the field so that's a really good
uh background to have
um and myself come from a
electrical engineering and computer
science background
so
um I always thought it was a good pivot
okay I think that that covers one more
question that just came in
so uh again this is is there a
difference between the postgraduate
program for professional certificate so
again I'll just say professional
certificate program from Purdue
University We have basically
rebranded that but again it's a program
that is a postgraduate program that
requires you to have a bachelor's degree
in order to join it so
um
the university asked us to just do a bit
of a nomenclature change there
um
and
we still do require for the professional
certificate the same prerequisites
um
so you would if you look on our website
uh under digital marketing courses you
probably won't find the postgraduate
program anymore you'll find the
professional certificate but you'll also
find the boot camp if you happen to be
in the US
so there are different levels and
flavors of our
digital marketing education programs
Skilling programs and
um
hope that answers that question for you
I'm still going to venture to say just
to add to what you're saying Stuart a
lot of the universities still do not
have specialized degrees for digital
marketing it is traditional marketing
and it may have some digital marketing
sprinkled in there so there is
relatively no do you still going to get
the same content the same course where
it's the same instruction it's no
difference between there but in terms of
having your job ready a lot of companies
are allowing experience over the actual
education because they also have
realized that you don't have a lot of
degrees that are built towards digital
marketing per se which we've been seeing
this acceleration for the last 10 years
I don't really understand why
universities are not building a program
specifically for additional marketing
but not every University does so you're
not going to be getting less or being
perceived less because you have a
professional certificate in it
um in fact you'll probably have more
because you're going to have a lot more
Hands-On and then you know my suggestion
is if you're straight out of high school
go with an internship for a few months
and then that will serve as your job
experience for
yeah
great okay and
um with that I'm just going to go ahead
and move on to
the last poll question
oops
re-share
and our final poll question
is simply if you are interested in
enrolling
when would you plan to do that
we asked this because we would like to
remind people that if this is something
that you would like to do it's always
worth doing it sooner than later if it's
going to make it an important difference
in your life I also mention that if you
are going to enroll in the cohort that
starts
November 7th specifically because you
are here today
you have the opportunity to claim a
discount of 500 off of the course fees
so when you contact
ask us to simplylearn.net if this is
something you want to do right away and
want to get into that November cohort
um please mention that and
be able to claim that 500 discount again
this only applies if you're planning to
join in that
um cohort specifically so
with that I'm going to share the poll
results here
about 60 percent of people want to do
this within three months which basically
means that November cohort because it
starts classes start in January so
that's within three months and
um again remember to ask for that 500
discount
for attending this webinar
really appreciate your being here so I
want to thank you for uh attending today
and I want to thank Bernadette
for sharing her
expertise and her industry knowledge
with us
absolutely
we hope that we will see you at future
webinars but we especially hope that we
can welcome you into the Purdue simply
learned learning community so
appreciate you all being here and that
concludes our webinar for today
all right bye-bye
now